um
i think for a lot of fans heels was a
bit of an intermediary step between
retired and wrestling for you was that
at all therapeutic for you to be
involved with a project that celebrates
the soul of pro wrestling for sure yeah
i think therapeutic is actually a good
word for it um yeah it was fun to be
involved in something that was wrestling
that wasn't wrestling and there's no
politics and
you know none of the none of the silly
drama that you have to deal with
backstage you know it was just uh it was
fun i said i've been saying it a lot
lately it was fun just making the art
not worried about anything else yeah
for sure
i think for me i i love that we have
shows like heels and glow because i feel
like in the 80s and 90s there was always
a big relationship between wrestling and
hollywood but it felt kind of
superficial to me um do you get the
impression having acted and been a part
of pro wrestling that there's maybe a
little bit more respect now from
hollywood because i feel like the
stories get to the heart of wrestling
more than they used to i think
the meek heaven inherited the earth i i
think a lot of people who are
shot callers are on their way to being
shot callers in hollywood now uh
used to be or are still are
huge professional wrestling fans i think
they grew up watching it
they get it
and now in their chosen profession they
get to kind of
you know turn the light on to it so to
speak shed a little bit more light on it
and show it the love that they've always
given it you know like guys like michael
waldron you know i mean
he's writing the next star wars movie
for christ's sake like dude loves pro
wrestling you know so he's he's the
writer on heels and that's what i mean
by like you know the meek inheriting the
earth it's like these people who grew up
with it are now
showing it the love that it deserves
and speaking of showing the love that it
deserves i love this new age of like
celebrity pro wrestlers the stephen
amells the pat mcafees the bad bunnies
because they're going in there and
really giving it a good impressive shot
how great has it been steven one of our
canadians that we love to boost up um
how great has it been having stephen
amell as an ambassador for pro wrestling
in hollywood and vice versa um i can't
say enough good things about stephen you
know i think steven is
not only an accomplished actor um you
know this is a guy that has gotten in
the ring on a number of occasions for a
number of different companies it wasn't
just about oh i need to wrestle in the
wwe for stephen it was just oh i need to
wrestle you know and he's wrestled for
wwe he has wrestled uh in ring of honor
um he did the the you know before aew
was a thing he did their their one-off
show here in chicago so
just a guy who follows his dreams uh who
does what he wants and he's just such a
he's just such a great dude and i think
that lends credibility to both sides of
things right like it helps heals out
tremendously um but it also helps out
the wrestling side of things you know
like and it makes heels
feel more of an authentic show when you
have somebody who's attached to it that
loves the source material so much
if we see a second season of heal
something i'm i'm hopeful for i know a
lot of fans are is there anything you'd
like to see touched on more considering
all the time you've had as a pro oh yeah
um i mean there's a million things you
know i think this is a show where we can
really
do what a show like friday night lights
did you know it's a show about football
but it's not really about football it's
about the people and the families and
the characters in this town and i think
we can do the same thing with heels i
think we can touch on
you know road trips um
you know awful behavior of wrestlers
steroids drugs concussions i i it is
real and i think we can tell those real
life stories while also you know peeling
back the characters that are just small
town america duffy georgia i think the
honestly sky's the limit
what does being a part of aew full-time
mean for your acting career moving
forward because obviously you're
juggling a lot you also have cffc
commentary dvds um what's what's your
acting credits looking like um
you know we're lining things up and
we're gonna cross that bridge when we
get to it you know like obviously uh
it's built into my deal with aw that i
have the freedom to explore other
opportunities um
you know and i have such a great
relationship with tony that all that it
really is a conversation you know i i
think the more visible i am the bigger
roles i do get i think it'll help aew
internally
uh and you know but
you know that being said it's just like
i am being pulled in a couple different
directions but my heart is 100
behind every single project i do and aew
being one of them it's uh it's going to
be a busy year but it's going to be a
great year
i can't imagine well it's been really
exciting to watch so congratulations on
that um
ring russ that's something people talk
about obviously you've been out for
seven years when you hear about ring
bust for you what was the hardest thing
to pick back up was it the moves was it
the timing was it the ear for the fans
and their reaction what was that i i
think it was just kind of quieting that
voice in my head that
that doubted anything you know um
cardio is fine
uh i i think
you know timing's fine
i was always a storyteller in the ring
you're never going to see me do like a
triple jump moonsault to the floor or
anything like that you know and it's
more just about tugging on people's
heartstrings and getting them to care
about me
as a as a human being really i think
that's the if i have an advantage over
anybody i think that's one of them you
know like i i have this rare connection
with the crowd
um
i i just think
i need more reps i need to get out there
more in front of a live audience and and
wrestle you know and then you know i'll
be i'll be back to form in no time not i
i mean i i i think i haven't missed a
fee like it was kind of the goal was to
go out there and make it look like i i
had been wrestling last week you know
what i mean i think mission accomplished
um
i just want to get out there and hear
the crowd more you know that's all i
want to do is be in that moment
well you have been getting out there in
the crowd quite literally jumping over
the barricade week after week there's
one that i thought was super amusing i
think it was the second time you jumped
and a fan appeared to offer you a beer
for those who may not be aware cm punk
lives a straight edge lifestyle
substance free um i thought it was
really funny made for a little gift but
what was going through your mind in that
oh i i the thing that was going through
my mind in that moment is man this guy's
lucky i'm not a heel right now but it
was a funny moment to me you know i was
just like this is hilarious like
i it sometimes it's not about the gift
the gesture is more important you know
for sure i agree i agree uh you've
written for marvel comics some stuff
with drax strong chi if i'm not mistaken
and both of those characters have had
these amazing forays onto the big screen
which under the radar marvel character
do you think that people don't know too
much about in hollywood or in the
mainstream would kill it if making that
transition from comics to movies
obviously i'm a marvel fan um
cinematic and comic book
and otherwise i think we're all crossing
our fingers for a really really well
done fantastic four movie and i'm a huge
ben grimm the thing guy so i think that
could be
that that next you know quote unquote
underrated character you know he's a lot
like drax you know like he's a big rough
tough looking mean guy but
you know he's gentle you know so i i
think that one given um
the same treatment they've given a lot
of other characters in the marvel
cinematic universe could really blow
people away
i think that'd be fantastic and hey i
can't help but think there might be some
sort of crossover uh advertising
campaign that would just be perfect
and there goes my wonderful dog um
pro wrestling
i think has been every time i see a pro
wrestler make the transition to
hollywood
i'm nervous because like i believe in
them so much and i hope that um they can
do right by themselves and that everyone
else kind of sees what myself and a lot
of other pro wrestling fans see dave
batista is i think the one that
appears to blow away every wrestler that
i talked to you got a lot of compliments
myself yourself
john cena guy you've shared the ring
with a lot um has been putting forward a
real a lot of really strong comedy
outings are you impressed with john
cena's development as an actor 100 but
i'm also not surprised i i think people
conflate the two right like um you see a
guy like dave bautista killing it
um with this myriad of different roles
like dave can do commentary or a comedy
dave can do um drama he can he can do it
all
cena's always been that funny guy and i
always saw it behind the scenes and i
think anybody who's worked with them
always saw it um
a lot of the guys at that top level in
wwe maybe not like to admit it but all
we are is theater actors we're doing
live theater
every monday every friday thursday
tuesday whatever the hell the schedule
is now
and all that is
is theater and it gets you accustomed to
improv and working on the fly and i
always i read james gunn said something
that you know john cena was the best
improv actor he's ever worked with and
that does not does not surprise me in
the least you know uh we do it every
every every week for you know decades
and when we transition to film i think
people are always pleasantly surprised
like oh wow yeah i thought you were just
going to be like this big muscled up
stiff guy and that's never the case not
surprised john's killing it
glad to hear it last thing here um my
girlfriend and i huge horror fans we
really loved girl on the third floor and
i get the sense that you yourself are a
bit of a horror nut so i yeah i wanna do
a little bit of an exchange here as we
wrap up i'd like you to give me three
under the radar horror movies or tv
shows and i'll return the favor
oh boy um
have you seen starry eyes
i have not check out starry eyes very
very well done film
um
i feel man i feel like everybody's eye
is on horror lately with all like the
the flanigan stuff on netflix and you
know halloween resurgence
um
i'll put you on the spot there's a
there's a corny film that i discovered
from the 80s called blood rage you
should check out um that's a it's a
great one
and for the third one oh
gosh
yeah you did put me on the spot here um
improv yeah improv [ __ ] uh
i want to try to cast some light on i
haven't seen i haven't seen it yet
uh but there's a movie called the
stylist that i want to check out um
indie horror
and i can't off the top of my head
recall the the writer director but she's
she's a fantastic talent and i can't
wait to watch the stylist so what do you
got
uh marianne or marianne it's a one seat
one season french
or tv show about this like omnipotent
witch that is just terrorizing a town
and a particularly an author because
she's trying to get the author to write
about her my wife my wife will like that
it's it's really good unfortunately we
just got one season under the shadows
it's an iranian language film based
during the iran iraq war about a gin
that sort of travels to anywhere where
there's trauma happening and the the
spirit is sort of uh personification of
the traumas of war that's pretty good i
really like it follows it's this like
curse that gets transmitted through
sexual intercourse and the monster takes
on any shape but it's only ever walking
towards you and the only way to pass it
on is to get freaky pretty interesting
one the way it's shot it's really cool
but anyways that's enough about me punk
thank you so much for this uh before i
let you go is there anything you want to
let the canadiens know oh gosh you know
i hope to see you soon i don't have any
any dates on my schedule but um you know
i i think with with covid and crossing
into canada i think it's a little bit
more tricky
um
but you know i i would also
like to remind canadians that no
canadians uh hockey team has won the
stanley cup in 30 plus years i love you
guys see you soon
vancouver riots for the win uh cm punk
phil brooks thank you so much no problem
thanks a lot
you